so the New York Times just published a
piece that I thought was kind of
fascinating about kids spas yeah full on
kids spas places called things like
sweet and sassy and seriously spoiled
Salon and
Spa that sounds just awful and literally
they are targeting kids I'm talking
about seven-year-old kids they're giving
them facials they're offering
kid-friendly music banana scented
facials they're driving around in limos
and of course they use age appropriate
vocabulary customers are princesses and
uh toes are
pigges um yeah so look at this I mean
look if you how I don't know how old
let's say those girls are maybe 10 12 or
so if you are 12 years old and you need
to put cucumbers on your eyes these are
not the kids that need that these
are the most pampered princesses on the
planet I mean this is literally going on
in New York City right now um yeah so I
thought this was interesting because we
live in a time where you know we always
talk about the the 1% even though it's
really the 0.1% and this middle class is
disappearing and the huge uh lower class
that's expanding and it's like wow
people could be so detached yeah that
you're sending your kids you're already
pampered kids who go to private school
and have every advantage on Earth and I
don't begrudge them any of that but then
you're sending them for cucumber facials
is this something they need to learn
that we need to like teach them from a
young age I like it to it's the parents
the parents are going I want them to be
shitty early I want to teach them how to
be shitty right out of the bat and I
like it it's like oh these cucumbers
take 10 years off your face you look
like you're a fetus yeah you look like
you're negative six yeah you look like
your dad's balls in
2006 I don't think she liked that one
you like that really but in a weird way
are these people setting up their kids
for like a really horrible life in in a
weird way because there's a good chance
that these kids will not be as
successful as their parents so when
they're eight years old and they're
getting facials and being driven around
in limos there's a good chance that
they're going to be less well off
economically than their parents and
they're going to go when I was
eight those were the good old days I was
having C the real world baby you got to
work yeah unless you got a trust fund
which you probably do they probably do
have a trust fund they absolutely have a
trust fund I was trying to find some
silver lining here there's there's
there's no Silver Lining to this I hate
to break this to you I hate to burst
that I hate to rain on your parade with
the shitty truth which is these kids are
going to be bad unless there's that
moment where they're like oh my God I I
can't believe I'm I'm this terrible or
maybe if the parents are smart and it
you know they probably won't send them
to the spa but if these parents are
smart they're like here here is living
well okay so we're going to take you to
the spa now to justify that we're also
going to make you work we're going to
show you what we do in order to provide
these nice things in life and I'm pretty
sure that's not going on I'm pretty sure
um what this was making me think was
when I was a kid and I was maybe 10 or
12 like I remember I really really
wanted to have a birthday party at
Chuck-E-Cheese like I had a couple
birthday parties at bowling alleys and I
was like this year I want Chuck-E-Cheese
and I remember that was like a I think
it did end up happening but like it was
a struggle to make that happen with my
parents you know I mean that was going
to cost more blah blah blah but I wanted
Chuck-E-Cheese Chuck-E-Cheese happened
God bless him but like just how
different you know what I mean like
everybody grows up in such a different
thing I'm sure someone else would have
grown up thinking that a bowling uh
birthday party would have been the
greatest thing it's all relative is my
point yeah and it's so she's got such
admiration what was your Chucky I like
Chucky oh my I got Chuck E cheese you
got chuckecheese what was something that
you wanted really bad that you had to
like work for there was like a a big
like compromise made where it's like all
right we'll give it to you well like you
know you need to dress like you're cool
when you're in elementary and middle
school and those clothes are expensive
and your parents are like hell no so
it's like okay you can have an allowance
but you have to work for it you can buy
it your damn self you know what's funny
I remember in uh like sixth grader
saying Champion t-shirts just a simple
Champion t-shirt was like the coolest
thing you could have and all my friends
had like 10 of them different colors
every day I had two Champion shirts I
wore them every other day I had a blue
one and a red one and that was my spa
that was my personal spa and I was happy
yeah me just Beluga caviar
mom not that shitty run-of-the-mill
whatever the Cav are you're giving
me
baluga is that so hard you
surf
[Music]
what